what's going on reject nation greg here
john i'm john he's judd and we got with
us today
a man who you don't offer he's sometimes
the front of the camera on his channel
his face is usually there as part of his
icon
for the channel however he's somewhat
who i've talked with many times we've
talked quite a bit over
uh social media very deep conversations
actually yeah funny enough recently
we've gotten into
very deep comment i'm like perfect this
is a good time to hop on an interview
with you um let's air out all that
personal life stuff
paul from heavy spoilers heavy spoilers
paul
tatted up kevin spoilers is here hmm
oh yeah where'd that name my new name
where'd that name kevin come from chris
from 3c films kept calling you kevin and
i was like i thought
it was paul what the hell's going on
yeah it is i was just trolling one day
and i just made it the sauce yeah i just
made up a sauce and
normally i say dude bro trust me
sometimes i say my uncle
and i was just like oh kevin spoilers he
he told me and
now i'm kind of thinking about going off
into a whole family family
with like my cousin kenny spoilers and
uh
yeah just just make a whole family of
them yeah you need to do cutaways
to just leave you in a mustache or
something and that's kevin spoilers or
like a fedora hat
henry spoilers the lot we'll get them
all out yeah there you go
if you guys don't know paul you should
yada uh he's blowing up right now
um often going trending on youtube all
the time that's why we're here because
we're going to capitalize on his
training right man we got to ride that
momentum right hotels
get us yesterday as well video
congratulations video's not monetized
doesn't matter
the biggest kick in the team the joy of
making it to the page
and to have such a well-performing video
honestly it's been about 24 hours since
we got demonetized for that video
and i'm still i've worked out twice
since then
and i'm still a little frustrated by it
i mean totally honestly so
there was a big glitch on youtube
yesterday in the uk
where any video uploaded after about
2 p.m yesterday just wasn't showing in
the search results at all
so i thought that had been shadow band
for quite a while because i was
searching
um venom you know i was literally typing
out the title i had and it wasn't
showing up in the search results
and now then i would search for my own
channel and the latest video was one
that i posted on sunday
so i was like have i been shadow banned
um because
ign was the only one showing up with
their breakdown with andy circus and i
was like there was some of the [ __ ]
sony have stamped the foot down and
trailer reactions and breakdowns are
dead
uh but yeah it was just an issue in the
uk i know
another youtuber who posted one and his
still isn't showing up in the search at
all
and mine is now but sometimes this is
the whole thing about being a youtuber
it just likes to kick you in the teeth
yeah yeah another example
launched a new t-shirt today it was
going to make a big campaign about it
it was fine it was on the store and for
some reason youtube just put it under
review again
and they've taken it off so all the work
i did today building that campaign
pointless
thanks youtube i'm so sorry guys buy a
heavy spoilers t-shirt we'll buy one
paul
leach by the way we'll help you out yeah
i wouldn't i won't send you a free one
you you have to buy it please right
i would like to pay more than the shirt
is worth in shipping please
yes where in the okay first off we're a
few minutes in here
if you guys haven't seen paul from heavy
sweaters he does these really great
breakdowns like really wonderful
breakdowns that and he's
known to be on top of it he's got quite
a reputation for being like the first
i constantly see a comment that says
that the first one out
yeah with a breakdown the king of
endings explained
and it pisses me off sometimes this
isn't even out yet
it convinces you i'm like right now it's
this is the earliest collab i've ever
done in my entire life the only times
i've done a collab at like five or six
in the morning is to
do a quick trailer reaction and
not have that guest hover over my
shoulder while i'm quickly editing and
i'm like please stop talking to me i'm
trying to get to work
yeah and yeah so this is like oh we're
about to do an interview at 8 30 in the
morning
so it's 8 30 our time and it's like what
it's like
uh 4 45 30 pm 4 30 p.m
your time so for example like we're
shooting this the day after
um the venom let there be carnage
trailer came out
and for us we had to get up at five in
the morning and then we shot it at 6 00.
yeah so we were like very pissed when it
got demonetized because i'm like man i
want to do all that studying at midnight
and get no sleep not
sleeping yeah and then but you're
you're you're on top of it and i'm like
tempted to move to the uk
just because of this time zone thing
where you're able to be like
yeah it's like three like three what
time was it when it came out for you
like three o'clock p.m
p.m god sounds incredible
so i tend to work between um about eight
till five
so it's right in the sweet part of the
day i i got it finished off before
five and yeah it's it's great disney
shows as well
i'll tell you what i love disney people
people call me a shill
they they drop those shows at 8 a.m in
the uk
and i tell you what i've i've speak to
some youtubers who are like man i had to
get up at
four in the morning to do a one division
breakdown
you've got 10 000 views and you got a
million on it and i hate my life and i'm
like well
sorry the uk
because most so most of your audience
i'm assuming is with
america though even though you're in the
uk yeah it is yeah
yeah so a lot of them's the losers who
stay up till
4 a.m when i'm you're talking about us
specifically yeah um but sometimes
when they obviously you know a video
takes a couple of hours to do
uh so by the time they wake up mine's
normally going live
yeah so it's like well we'll watch kevin
spoilers and
none of the good channels have got
theirs out yet because they won't be so
it foreign and now you're on press list
too for certain companies so
then yeah then you get like early access
for things on top of that
yeah it's kind of a double-edged sword
because
i can't really talk about leaks all that
much anymore um because
it so you know that that's kind of how
my channel built its reputation was
reporting on leaks um and then i
reported on one that was quite accurate
and gotten
not i didn't get in trouble for it but
it was just like
it seemed better to not do it as much
anymore so
now i'm kind of just like doing
breakdowns the spoilers are coming
after the show almost it's like we've
watched it
we want to hear these spoiler reviews
let's do it because
spoiler free reviews they only have a
certain audience um
it's normally people who haven't seen it
yet whereas i'm there
you know you've taken the the woman that
you love out for a meal
you've kissed her in the taxi you've
said goodbye dropped her off at
home your boys have got on the phone
they're like let's go out
and party and that's who i am i'm i'm
the guy who's like the party after the
the spoiler-free thing you see what i'm
saying yeah does that metaphor work
absolutely that's a really long time
i mean criticism i clearly have a lot of
experience with my funko pop so
having a heavy nightlife yeah this is an
easy way to
make people think that we know what
we're talking about oh yeah it's just a
green screen
yeah this is the party repeated in for
this zoom interview today yeah
it's just a department store so the
stock room
i'm i'm very curious um
your intros whenever you do um
you have some like i call them like i
can't tell if it's british humor or dad
jokes or a little bit of both
that's kind of the vibe that i get with
a lot of your like your puns and stuff
do you ever stress about the first
yeah i'm generally stressed i'm
generally stressed yeah i'm stressed
right now
do you ever um uh stress over
like what the hell is my opening joke
that i gotta make
right now yeah no 100 and
with everything getting delayed um some
of the jokes
were i mean the batman was something i
must have done about 50 videos on
and by about video 20. i was like
it's the the death knight because i used
to be called definition and
death death knight and it was just so
bad and when they kept pushing the
movies back i just thought how am i
gonna keep doing this and sometimes i'll
just start a video off by just
skipping that and going okay so we're
gonna get into the breakdown straight
away
if you enjoy it okay click the thumbs up
and i just skip it all yeah it's very
stressful and i know
3c films does something i mean his
aren't as creative as mine you know he
doesn't put as much effort into
to coming up with crap
but yeah it takes all green screens with
that guy
oh yeah
what other youtube channels do you watch
by the way because i see your
i see your like name just pop i remember
i saw some like
financial i hit you up about this i'm
like financial strategist
youtube channel and i'm like yeah
there's freaking heavy spoilers
it's right here it's commenting yeah i
feel like you're like you're plugged
into
so much and i'm really plugged in like a
little bit so
i i get some like um and
it's it's some news network owned by
universal or something that
is out in colorado or something and all
their
that like network presenters follow me
like the weatherman from there followed
me one day and i was like
i don't know what's going on and then
all of the the presenters start
following me
um and it's just really weird i think
it's good i cover
such a broad range of subjects um
initially i started out doing netflix
specifically um ending explains on that
and then
kind of got into comic book stuff i mean
i've always been in the comic books
i just for some reason never saw it as
my avenue in youtube
even though i kind of i did start off by
covering
um frank miller and batman graphic
novels
and then that kind of went into netflix
which is really weird and now it's kind
of came full circle
to to being back to comic books but yeah
it's it's
crazy how many people will just pop up
because i posted some
some video from years ago on some stupid
subject that i don't even
remember watching really weird what is
your youtube origin tale
well first off how old are you if you
don't mind me asking 32
32. so quite old to be getting into
youtube
um so i just i mean like what was your
what was your career before you were
doing youtube okay so
i started working in a bar when i was
about 15
um and i did 10 10 years of just working
in a bar
and it was it got to a point where i was
like
i'm just gonna be doing this forever and
i want to actually get
like a career um so not saying that
doing ball work isn't a career but i
just was losing my interest with it
and i started applying to places and
they were like well
no you you've only got bar experience so
we're not going to take you on
um and then i got a call back from a
call center
and i remember going in and thinking
i've finally made it i've got a desk
this is the thing i've been wanting my
whole life this is what i imagined
success to be
and that was really soul-destroying as
well and then i realized the grass
wasn't always greener
and i thought you know i'm interested in
doing the internet and stuff like that
and but i don't really know where to
start so i messaged
a lot of companies saying and this this
is when twitter and facebook was just
starting out
and i messaged them just saying look you
i know you haven't really got much of a
presence
online um i will run your social media
accounts for free for three months
just so i can get some stuff on my
resume nice
and i started doing that nice hustle and
then
that kind of got my my my social network
skills
but basically everything i've done in my
life is sort of built towards me
being a youtuber um and that kind of
so from the social network side of
things that kind of developed into
doing um web design i'd never designed a
website in my life
and i applied for a job which was a
graduate apprenticeship which is
basically where
a university pays a company owner to
give one of its graduates a course um
so i i did music at university which
went nowhere but i had a degree
so i could apply for that and i became a
website designer and i remember going to
the interview and was like look i've
never
not really built a website i said i
built a myspace page and they're like
all right
okay that sounds pretty good they got me
in
um i did about a year of that
and then the guy sadly he just
i remember him coming and because i was
the only person who worked for him and i
worked from home
and he he came in and was like oh i'm
really sorry
the the company's just not doing well um
i'm gonna have to let you go
so i was a bit guided and we just moved
into our house
i'd actually said to him before we moved
in look am i gonna have a job next year
and he was like yeah yeah definitely
and then about three weeks later i
didn't have a job oh my dude
yes which sucked and then i started work
i basically spent the next couple of
weeks looking for web design jobs
managed to get one
worked for a guy and then out of the
blue
uh after about three weeks in i got an
email from
one of his previous employees saying be
careful this guy is a con man
he doesn't uh he doesn't pay people he
just gets them to build websites
takes control of it and then doesn't pay
them and that turned out to be true
so i had basically moved into a new
house
uh lost lost a job got another one
didn't get paid for it
and then you know i got this email and
i didn't know at the time he wasn't
going to pay me but i was very very
suspicious
so i just started looking around at
places and i got a job
actually working at a coffin factory and
doing coffin designs
so i don't know if you've seen them that
is a specialist
special skill yeah
so so basically what would happen is
you'd get a custom-made coffin and now
they
can print images onto it so you could
send in loads of photos or you could say
i want a coffin to look like a race car
or something like this
heavy spoilers heavy spoilers yeah yeah
and this is where i slowly developed my
um
photoshop skills so i built up the
social media skills so straight
up the website skills um whilst i was
doing websites i also kind of
learned a lot of seo yeah i got the
photoshop skills
and then uh i just i it was about an
hour and a half journey every morning
on the bus so i used to always take a
comic with me to read
because i'd be three day three three
hours a day on the bus and i just used
to start
reviewing them start reading them just
writing down
my my thoughts on my phone and because i
knew how to build a website i just
thought i'll just put these on a website
and
people will come read them uh and then
it was rough so this is when i started
doing the batman
frank miller graphic novels and then the
extended edition of
batman v superman came out and i thought
i'll just do a video on that
and i started uh just you know talking
into my phone
had some footage playing over the top
and that got about six thousand views in
a day
nice which when you're starting out is
that insane you're crazy yeah six
thousand people
even today that would be really good so
i thought oh that well it's clearly
an audience in youtube so i started just
reviewing
films instead of working on my website
which is why my websites went to crap
now but then
got all this youtube stuff so that's
pretty much
how how it's been so of yeah every
everything i've done so far
as far as the social media photoshop web
design seo
that's all kind of come together to
enable me to work on
on youtube and i remember going for a
job interview once
and the guy was like you're a jack of
all trades you've got all of these
skills
but there's not a specialist one and
there's not really any jobs in the
market for that
looking back though there is youtube
just as long as you can do
a range of different things bring them
together
and you've got it because that's what
you need to be a youtuber you need to
have good thumbnails
good titles that rank well good videos
and reviews that you've been typing on
your website
so there's go off and do that big story
kids and you'll
just become like your uncle kevin
spoilers that is
i got i've it's been a long time since
someone has told me
i don't think it's ever actually
happened somewhere someone tells you
their life story
yeah yeah i'm sorry how did so how did
you
create your youtube channel can we go
further back into your child's part
1985. what did you do before the no i'm
saying that like
i legit at one point got
nipple chills hearing your story because
i was like
wow that's crazy you have like the
inspiring tale of someone who has been
working since they were a teenager
trying to just make ends meet struggling
sounds like you you got married before
any of this any youtube and all that
happened you were at least with your
you're with your significant other at
least by this point yeah so i met my
wife in 2015
and i started youtubing properly
uh in 2018 i think it was crazy she's
not a gold digger yeah
don't don't tell them
yeah a head to spoiler
but no that's that's pretty awesome
that's inspiring
like especially like you got like an
eminem eight mile story riding that bus
writing down your comic book dots
and then being able to transition here
it does
yeah out of any story i've heard about
getting into youtube
that is the first one i've heard where
i'm like oh this sounds like it's
meant to be for you uh that's yeah
that's pretty surprising
but yeah and now obviously we've been
talking about this interview for a while
i've been thinking about what i'm going
to say in it
and i was watching chris's the other day
and he was saying how he thinks
his channel is going to get taken away
the next day and i'm very much of the
the same mind as that and i was doing a
cycle
yeah it's it's so weird and i've done
like a psychological deep dive on myself
to kind of
figure out why i get such bad anxiety
over it and i think it is because i
bought this house
uh didn't really have the money to pay
for it moved in
got fired from a job got another job
worked that for a month didn't get paid
then had to get another job
and i had like these two things just
taken away from me so fast
that when it comes to youtube as well
i'm just like
this is going too good you know
something's something's going to happen
here where it just all gets taken away
which is nice that constantly going
through the back of your head
so you're trying to be positive making
videos it's a good discipline
strategy i kid you not ev every time
things start going great
one last my fiance was right here in
this corner sitting in a chair
and she's like every time things go good
for you
you start freaking out waiting for the
other shoe to fall
and i'm like but you you don't
understand
like everything has i mean there was a
point where we we lost the channel
for a while yeah we lost we lost the
channel for like a month
all because they used to be linked to um
what was it
google they changed the way that the
youtube accounts interact with your
gmail or whatever and our channel had
been created prior to that
and there was something in the
transitioning over into the new
you know technological regime or
whatever that just didn't
quite click properly for our channel so
when we were trying to troubleshoot a
different issue
we managed to basically dislodge the
channel from any
email address so just kind of floating
out there in the ether and they had to
basically come in and attach it to a
brand new gmail
and this was during uh you know december
as you know when ads are
like thriving really yeah yeah so that
is christmas that is christmas on
youtube though yeah
we got our money to figure out our
channel back in january like
perfect in this time
enjoy january money i mean it was like
uh
because i before john and i really like
partnered up like hardcore together
because there's like a whole
history with us but before then
when it was mainly just me i had the
experience of dealing with adpocalypse
and i think you started really
thriving here before like a little after
that all occurred based off of the
timeline of what you told me
and that traumatized me because like all
right the income of the real rejects
shot down like
90 for like two months and it was
terrifying because i i didn't save and i
i grew up pretty poor like i was very
very poor
did you i think we talked we touched a
little bit about this on social media
did you
it sounds like you grew up with some
financial struggles too right yeah
um we weren't like poor but a lot of
there was a lot of time when we didn't
know how much money was coming in like
my family's working class which you know
what what comes with that is
you will have your good months and then
you'll have a lot of
ones that where you're sort of on the
ropes my dad self-employed and my mum
was a hairdresser
and then they split up and that's kind
of caused a lot of issues
and money-wise but yet it
was i wouldn't say i was like living in
poverty
but there was a lot of you know
difficulties
i ended i ended up going to quite a a
posh school
and where a lot of people were quite
well off and i
i feel bad saying it but i always feel
like when i'd see their parents buying
them cars and stuff and
i would not even be getting like clothes
it was just a bit mm-hmm i mean i
did but they did buy me clothes i don't
want to say but there was a i was
naked yeah at the time i never really
felt like i was poor but then when i
went to this school where everyone was
quite well off it was like
oh so this is actually like the how the
other half live sort of thing
yeah yeah but yeah my parents never used
to waste money they
would always put me and my sister first
and everything so i don't want to sound
bad on them but yeah i mean i think that
fear though
like i think when you grow up with that
because like every mr household
specifically like i we every month we
were afraid we were going to lose the
house
like every every month it was like that
and i feel like that
fear has just sort of translated into
my lifestyle now that i'm really trying
to i'm really
actively working on overcoming by just
talking about it first yeah
and no definitely and i saw with the
youtube kind of being this like
very up and down relationship and uh
like it's it's it's it's hard it's
difficult
yeah and that's what a lot of people who
on
who don't do youtube they think it's a
very easy job
and you're just sitting about making
videos all the day but
if you have a day where you you don't
have a story to cover or
you your views dip all like the one
yesterday where
youtube just decided not to show my
video to anyone
that's like a day's wages lost um and
you wonder how
oh crap is this the new normal it's a as
a human
you spend a lot of times when you get in
a rut you
just instantly think this is how things
are and this is how things are always
going to be
and you forget that there are you know
peaks and troughs
that basically make your career on
youtube i'm kind of getting more used to
the idea now like i've had quite a bad
month this month
but i've had so many bad months before
that it's just kind of like well
you know loki's coming next month and
i'm sure you'll bounce back with that
but last year was so difficult because
i i remember thinking oh crap i've got
nothing to cover for the next three
months
10 it comes out in july if i can make it
a 10 it i can do it
and then in june i think 10 it got
delayed
and i was like
so yeah it's got to make your heart sink
it's very
when your job is to be popular you are
going to have
a lot of existential crises
over your popularity especially when it
dips especially when you aren't popular
anymore like i i trended
every week with one division for quite a
while and that week i didn't trend
it was a oh crap what have i done wrong
has it gone now
yeah this sucks i mean that's why
i deleted the uh the youtube
uh that the youtube creator studio app
on my phone yeah
cause i just can't handle i can't handle
the feedback youtube gives me
brutal brutal when like your video is
performing
better than usual then i get all this
gratification
yeah and then it says your videos i'm
like
[ __ ] i'm a failure failure like this it
all like just kicks in these childhood
thoughts just kick in
yeah like i talk to my
friends quite a lot who aren't really
they don't know what's going on
in the back end of youtube and i'll say
things like r to 10 of 10
and they'll not know what that means and
basically if you are watching this and
don't know what it means
when you post a video it gets ranked
against your last 10 videos
so if you get a one they actually have
fireworks
as an animation to show how well you're
doing
and and one means you have this is the
best video you've done out the last 10
the views it's killing it on the views
this is you you've made it you've made
it
go treat yourself you are a success yeah
exactly
here's some fireworks confetti and
then 10 of 10 is oh well this is done
worse than all of your other videos
and if you get several 10 of tens in a
row it's like
but even anything reaper that shows up
yeah even even anything below a four i
start thinking like oh crap
for like a f a four five and a six back
to back is this is this it
says the down yeah it's really difficult
yeah a couple things i wanted to
touch on was just kind of like the
things i'm naturally curious
about when talking with others because
it's funny like my
i did an interview with chris and
and then uh and then we got like so
emotional about like the youtube side
and then i got messages from other
youtubers i know it's like a lot of
people
like that video did not a lot of people
watched it but then surprisingly like
people like you uh
a really close friend of mine warren
from cosmic wonder he he watched it too
and other people like hitting me up
about like you know like yeah i really
identify with that i was like [ __ ] at
least we found like a voice for
something
like for people who have a hard time
with this and so there are like
areas that i'm just naturally curious
about when it comes to
uh doing youtube so it's funny like john
and the lifestyle like my childhood home
was rough
but my school life was all right and
john's school life he dealt with
like we went to school together and he
had like all the bullying to deal with
and weirdly i feel like he can
handle hate comments better than
i do i mean how do i have a heart
after a while i just start getting like
i'll [ __ ] you i'm going to go on
so i have to just avoid comments how do
you personally deal with
because i see i you know like you you
have to you do a wide variety of videos
and
do you how do you deal with hate
comments um
i re it's really depends on what mood
you catch me in to be honest
sometimes i just laugh them off and
think that's great and then there'll be
something that's such
like a pedantic thing that it's like
i just it just really winds me up that
i've i've made it
i wrote like a 6 000 word video
spent hours recording it and editing it
designing the thumbnail and graphics for
it and then
the only thing that one person can take
from it is a a thing where i've misspoke
or something
it's always what yeah it was one where i
called it
we were doing one division and i called
wanda agatha just for its
like the the scene i was like oh and
agatha does this but i meant to say
wonder
and so many people were just like you
said uh
you said agatha instead of wondering
yeah and i was just saying oh is this
the only thing that these people are
taking from this video that
this 25 minute video this one word i got
wrong
in a 6 000 word essay and it's like so
that kind of winds me up
but whenever i argue with someone in the
comments
the next day i always feel like it was
something really stupid
like the the the other week i had um
[Music]
i posted a tweet about how i wish
streaming services would realize there's
more than just friday
and someone was like well we work
through the weekend
you we we we want to have the weekend to
watch shows
um and i would just say yeah but like it
would be better
you can watch things on the night you
know i mean there's tv shows
don't just air on a friday you have tv
shows on monday tuesday wednesday
thursday night
you say oh you stupid snowflake you get
so offended when people have a different
opinion and i'm just like oh just can't
be like just
i just said enjoy i just said enjoy your
mute
and then they blocked me and it was such
a stupid argument but it's something
that i just think i shouldn't have
stooped to that level because
this person's an idiot and i'm just
arguing with them
um and then they moved loki to wedding
stays
and i just thought i told you that
they're gonna have to do
stuff that guy works at disney plus you
talked to
us he went back was like oh dude i got
muted we gotta move it
yeah it's just stupid things like
someone the other day wrote
i did the bad batch breakdown and i was
talking about how
they were registering um in the second
world war they they registered jewish
people
um and i said that it happened in poland
i didn't mention the the yahtzee word
because obviously you get demonetised
straight away
and but there was someone saying i'm
going to report you to the authorities
for
saying that it happened in poland
because you're making it sound like the
polish people did it when it was
actually the germans
and i was just like uh yeah
no if i said the germans did it in
poland during the second world war
surely you think oh well i know exactly
who that is but they were
just weird comments like that you'll get
people who freak out over this stupidest
little thing
and it can be funny sometimes but when
you've had a long day
and you've spent hours and hours making
a video it's just like
is this it just arguing with people over
stupid semantics
it is it is incredibly especially that
first one you pointed out when you're
you put a lot of work in
to make just just everything of just if
people don't realize like it does take a
while to even for like something simple
like like a quick trailer reaction can
actually take some time to like
gotta make this thumbnail just pop right
and i gotta like i gotta quickly edit
this blah blah blah
but if we do like a breakdown or
something or a long discussion
and if you get one thing wrong sometimes
i try to defuse that i'm like let me
put it in the pin comment and it just
seems like
there's so many people who are quick to
rush to that comment box
to correct you when i'm like can't you
see there's already a gazillion other
people who have
already done this and i'm not going to
speak yeah oh yeah that's the thing
everyone seems to be under the
impression that they're the only person
who could have possibly noticed
even though you would have noticed it
probably straight away
but it's too late because it's live yeah
and yeah it's just
i mean youtube editor can help and
sometimes you can just cut sections out
of videos
uh but yeah it can be a bit frustrating
because
you will make mistakes if you're a
youtuber you
you i don't care who you are you will
make a mistake
um you think it's going to be really
easy i'll never do this and i've talked
about things that i know
off by heart like got such a massive
thing in my brain a whole section
dedicated to this one subject
and i'll make a mistake on something
still um and if you said it in a
conversation with your friends
it wouldn't really matter but because
it's published and it's
fixed and final and you can't change it
it's just very frustrating and people
kind of like to dunk on you
and i i find with social media that
now because a lot of people can
instantly get in touch with you uh
that if they want to be negative they
definitely will
so yeah it can be a bit frustrating but
to be fair i get quite a lot of positive
comments as well
um i just think everyone in general i've
spoken to
you could get a thousand positive
comments and one negative one
and you will just sit and if you have an
uh if you reply
if you respond to that person as well
you will literally just check
that comment over and over to see when
they responded like um just can't wait
did i get a spun
did i get them yeah or they kind of come
back
that's right i always kind of think of
it like i won't remember this argument
in a week's time
so don't bother getting involved with it
i don't think i ever remember the name
of
i don't think i've ever remember the
name of anyone who i've argued with
like yeah not on youtube yeah i don't
know the
don't think i know of one user's name
when you've gone back and forth with
them like i don't even remember what
that person's name is yeah
and it doesn't look good like i seen a
screenshot today of james gunn
arguing with someone on instagram about
no how they weren't making
the snyder verse and it was james gunn's
fault because he hadn't told
warner brothers that they should do it
and james gunn was arguing with this
person and i just thought
like that jay-z lyric don't argue with
fools because people from a distance
can't tell who is who
so just i just try and keep out of it
and i think every youtuber hits a point
where
they just stop responding to comments
because
they know what they're in for and it's
normally
arguments and you just haven't got the
time to do it or the energy
when i first started out on youtube i
was responding every comment heart and
every comment
and there's so many positive people out
there that i wish i could respond to
them all but
you i will and i'll try my best to and
then i'll just hit a negative comment on
the video and i'll just think uh
ruin my day yeah yeah that's the problem
is uh
i i feel like we do better when
it's weird like the less i know what
people are thinking about me
the better of a job i can do to keep
them happy
you know before you can let go yeah and
yeah feedback i'm getting involved with
about
me or something the better i can do yeah
well yeah well youtube that and that's
this is kind of what i was saying before
youtube's like a weird
environment for this like you don't go
to a movie watch it and
you can't instantly get in touch with
the director and tell them
exactly what you feel and the director
is not sitting there
reading what you're saying you know what
i mean so but youtube you can
so it's such a weird environment and but
it can help you quite a lot though
sometimes people actually do offer
constructive criticism
um i used to record in my phone
with the camera on and i just remember i
got a comment one day saying
you know what you're saying is good but
your
camera is terrible and your sounds
terrible if you got a good microphone
you could do quite well and that kind of
stuck with me
and that was something i actually used
um so sometimes it can be positive
there are gems like that like i can
think back to times where even we've had
that we're like there's somebody in the
comments who
who randomly has some kind of technical
mindset who can see what you're doing
enough to give you an actual piece of
constructive feedback like it is
like little unicorns yeah and it is
worth sifting through the comments for
that but i know i've probably killed
most of the comments on my videos now
because people be like well i'm not
gonna bother because he doesn't reply
but i read them all yeah i do read most
of them yeah i'll see you reply to quite
a bit
and i think you're pretty good generally
at handily i remember on like the bad
batch episode one breakdown like
i my my memory is not the greatest when
it comes to like certain properties so
like
yeah we had just we have to start bad
batch episode two
and i was like crap let me uh let me try
to refresh my memory on the first
episode so i watched your breakdown
and then i saw like you got something
like off about the clone force 99 yeah
like this 20 minute video everyone's
[ __ ] corrected you about this one
thing you got wrong and
but the way you handle it i'm like
that's a great sarcastic approach to
handling
like these hate comments i feel like i
can learn something from
how you handle it but like but behind
the scenes even sometimes when i take
the good sarcastic approach i'll be like
that [ __ ] like it's so like
riled up yeah
and sometimes people try and drag you in
beef as well they think they're being
nice but
they'll like drag you into beef so i get
compared to new rock stars quite a lot
and there'll be people who are like oh i
just want to see like
smash new rock stars one of these days
and i'm just like
thanks i guess but i'm really i really
do boxing match
between you and eric voss i'm just like
i really enjoy the channel
and i hope that like eric boss doesn't
randomly just open the video and see me
condoning these comments because
there'll always be a thumbs up on it
and it'll probably be the person liking
it themselves but
that'll look like it's me yeah and i'm
just like oh no
dragged into this again i like someone
tweeted me last night saying i want to
see canadian lad and heavy spoilers have
a fight
my money's on canadian lad and like
do i respond to that and say well i'll
kick his ass
or do i just ignore it but i i get i'm
guessing that canadian lad is probably
sitting there eating it thinking
i'm dragged into a fight as well and
it's just kind of like
we just all exist in this bubble where
there's a lot of respect
we don't really most youtubers don't
really acknowledge each other which is
really weird i try to if
i'll give people shout outs or i'll make
self-deprecating remarks about myself
um and it's it's a really weird space
but just getting dragged into like drama
and
getting people who want to see you fight
each other over marvel breakdowns is a
bit
it's a bit weird a bit weird i agree i
mean i think that's uh one of the first
things you and i talked about on twitter
uh was how i i feel like there's this
weird thing where people compete with
each other here on the
youtube platform and it really hit me a
while ago
and there's actually one the other thing
i wanted to ask you about um
because it hit me a while ago like
what's the point of competing
on youtube i feel like we should just be
like respect
we should be like as much of a community
as possible like amongst each other like
there's
people could easily watch like i could
watch your video and watch canadian last
video like it's not a problem i don't
need to
i don't need you i don't need to like
have you guys compete for my own
entertainment
and i don't like the feeling of
competing well i think is the problem is
i have a really big issue
with uh comparing myself
that i i think everyone does and so do
you
do you personally have that because i
know you were just talking about like
wanting to not have this drama or this
competition but do you have that issue
too with comparing yourself
yeah and youtube is it's not like any
other business because if you work in
burger king
even if you're next door to mcdonald's
you don't know what sales they're making
you don't know how many customers are
going through their doors youtube you
can search
and see the results for other people so
i i dropped a trailer breakdown
yesterday
i was checking the search out and i was
like what why is this video doing better
than mine
um and yeah it's just it's difficult not
to get sucked into it sometimes though
competition can make you
improve like me and chris we started out
roughly the same time on youtube
and we we never spoke to each other for
about a year but
behind the scenes i knew we had like a
psychic connection
where we both knew we both knew we
absolutely hated each other
and we're just constantly trying to
outdo the other one
and we kind of compare it to the
prestige the two magicians yeah
the two magicians are just trying to
one-up each other all the time
and we were we were clearly trying to do
that with each other so much
and i think when you're first starting
out you are kind of
you've got so many people who all also
just started a youtube
channel that day who are doing the exact
same thing as you
and you're all trying to break away from
each other and stand out
and there was so many youtubers back
then when me and chris were doing it
that aren't here now but me and
chris still are and i think it's kind of
because we developed this competitive
rivalry where we were always just
pushing each other
to to level up like if you go back to my
early videos
they're absolutely terrible oh my dog's
just coming oh my god i was going to ask
about it
this is like the baby you're in a pair
if i didn't see
like her shoulder there i thought you
were in paranormal activity for a second
literally my next question
my wife does exist people are saying you
should do it like um
ralph on one division
just keep referring to it's just an
actor you've possessed
yeah so at some point i was going to ask
about her next that's so funny
yeah so so me and chris we constantly
were just going head-to-head on the same
topics
same subjects and from that we both kind
of developed what worked for each other
but
i would beat him he would beat me it's
like you know in peter pan
the the indians and the um the lost boys
they'll catch each other and then
they'll be like oh set them loose
why have you set them loose because
sometimes we win sometimes they win
and that was pretty much mine and
chris's relationship on youtube with
just one of us would win
and the other would win and we just keep
bettering it you know trying to get
better but youtube is quite good for
that you know it's never
it's never a monopoly i don't feel i
feel sometimes
it'll push smaller channels to have a
good day and then
you'll have a bad one but then the next
week it'll push you to have a good one
yeah so that is pretty much the how i
viewed competition
and then it just got to a point where me
and chris just reached out to each other
and we were like this is exhausting uh i
really respect you
i've been going head to head with you
for the past year you've been waiting
taking a lot of energy out of me yeah
and that was the thing i think i i just
saw so many of those other channels drop
off
that he was like well this guy you know
he's he's had me going
at him every single day for the past
year he's still here
i really respect that because i know how
hard i've been working
i know he's been working very hard so
that's good and now i'm kind of just in
a place where
i'd i'm not scrapping out with the
smaller channels so i'm not
that bothered about you know being
negative or hating someone
i'm just like i'll happily message your
channel and just say like
this is something you should do um i
remember jay book studios i hadn't
spoken to him before
and i saw that he got a copyright strike
on a video and i messaged him just
saying
look that sucks that you've got that
strike here's
how you fill in the form um and how you
kind of
deal with that and even the other day um
lamar wilson reached out and was like
i've got a big question to ask what font
do you use in your thumbnail
he said i've asked so many youtubers
have been asking for months and months
and no one's ever told me
i just said oh just agency it's called
and he was like thank you so much i
can't believe no one's told me this but
you said it was just the difference
between old youtube and you youtube
where
i think the new community's a lot more
giving um and supportive
and when people are getting one division
screeners and i wasn't there was so many
people who
were just like oh well here's an email
address message them and see if you can
get it which is really really nice
uh because i know two years ago that
wouldn't have been the case it would
have been like
you're trying to take my views yeah get
the hell out of here
no you're 100 right about that i think
it's a lot more apparent now just within
the youtube
space of what it's like to both be
on the creator side and on the audience
side so i get the sense there's a lot
more respect for just what the obstacles
and struggles are
now rather than people just being like
ah stop whining yeah yeah
yeah because i i mean we've been doing
this since like 2013
and uh now i have to i usually act
there's a subconscious part of my brain
that will kick off
if someone asks for help like an email
or something or whatever
yeah where i get a resistant immediate
like i guess that is just resist some
subconscious reaction that comes up of
like i don't want to do it and
and i have and then i actively go well
now i got to do it
because that that's like this is not the
person i want to be so like anytime i
get asked for something from a
fellow you know colleague or something
like if you want to ask or whatever i
would
if i'm like no i go oh [ __ ] now i really
gotta help out
yeah because i gotta fight again the
more time yeah the more times that you
kind of
give advice as well you realize it
doesn't really make a difference very
true yeah the amount of
advice i've given now in channels i'm
still here
and it's like yeah cool there's not
there's no
i mean we've just opened up the space
more to
for more people to come in and we're all
eating which is good
no one's taking food out of anyone
else's mouth youtube pays a stupid
amount of money
so yeah just it's it's a nice
environment at the moment
but the war will start again soon
[Laughter]
really quick i think i would like to end
off here i have um
there's some i didn't even talk with
chris about this uh much
uh but we were kind of touched and like
this is
i'm gonna be a little mindful of how
much i reveal and you can be a little
mindful of how much you reveal too but
you've been in a relationship for a
while
and you started growing in youtube
while you were in this relationship and
it's done like a lot of financial
benefits for you you have a great career
going and all that
but i understand the struggle of
being able to have a proper relationship
or just go on trips and travel and stuff
uh can you touch on that like because i
like right now i'm trying to plan like a
one little week
okay i'll give a quick example it's just
to give johnson yeah i want to give john
some credit here
because i had to go to colorado to to
look at some venues
and then um and so john had to like hold
down the fort here
uh while i was gone and i've been having
the hardest time
just even getting him to have like a day
off like it's been like
two little half days since and even then
i'd have to like call him up be like
dude this is big problem i need your
help
so and and like you got loki coming up
and i know you had like this trip
planned to go there
and i know the like my my fiance can get
and it's understandable of you know like
i'm doing this all the time
and there's this fear that if you stop
doing you're committing to it it's going
to drop off it's going to fall off
so it's hard to just kind of it's it's
hard to choose the rest of life
sometimes it's
hard to commit to person to things
outside of here
yeah because you never know what the
[ __ ] is going to drop
yeah or like you never know the
importance so i don't really know what
my
specific question is but like can you
just touch on that a little bit of how
that's been
yeah it is difficult and when i was
doing a full-time job alongside youtube
it was very very difficult
because we would go to the cinema on a
friday night watch the film
get in about you know 11 o'clock
and i would just go to work until 2am
then i'd wake up the next morning
my wife would want to do something i'd
be like i can't there's
a superman announcement or something
so i'd have to work through the day it's
i thought it would have gotten easier
when i i dropped the the full-time job
but it hasn't because
i'm trying to make my videos better so
i'm actually spending more time on them
and yeah it does just eat away at your
life like we we
booked a trip around loki
so it was going to be i'd i'd finish
about
2 p.m and get the video out on the
friday
go to the the resort come back on the
thursday night
and then be back in for loki the next
day and then they moved it to wednesday
and it was just like my trips just
ruined i'm gonna have to work
and we we kind of went back and forth
whether to cancel it or not
and my wife's really supportive she was
like just work
but it's kind of like i wanted some time
off for a while because 2020 i didn't
take any time off
um because i was just in survivor mode i
just thought
i have to this job is not going to last
because
there's no movies coming out so i just
have to keep working
and even now i'm still kind of in that
mind state of
if i stop working the money's going to
stop we're not going to be able to live
anymore
i'm going to have to go back to working
for someone else
i've worked so hard for this i want to
hold on to it as tight as i can
and that can kind of come at the expense
of your personal relationships
it's it's one of the best jobs in the
world to do
but it's so taxing and yeah
you know for it to be the best job it's
going to require some sacrifices
and that really really can be quite
straining sometimes
so we we went back and forth between do
we cancel this trip
we looked at all the other the other
times in the air and i was like well can
we not move the
the trip back to another another month
and she was like paul is there's never
going to be another month
there's never going to be another week
something will always
always come up yeah and i remember
working christmas day
um but we we had christmas dinner
and then the wonder woman
hbo max thing came out and i just was
sat
under the dinner table out of the way of
the living room
typing up the script for the video and
it was just
you can't have time off and you have to
give up those personal things
and it's such a cliche because i know if
we become parents or something
it's going to be like the dad who's
never never gets to spend time with his
kid because he's always trying to put
food on the table
and yeah it is it it cause it causes
stress
and but my hope is that i can retire
younger because of it
and then live out the good days live out
my winter years
yeah but you just don't know and this
job
literally could end tomorrow so it's
like you have to do it whilst the sun's
still shining
if that makes sense it does make sense
you've gotta
put plant the seeds whilst the sun's out
or something
make hay you got this kevin yeah you did
it but you're gonna have no personal
life
if you want to become a youtuber
unfortunately i was gonna say you
mentioned
like studying music and stuff where do
your then like other passions and
hobbies fit into all that
too yeah i mean i used to be such a big
gamer
um i just used to play computer games
like four or five hours a day
i was really good at them as well not
just blowing my own trumpet like really
good at them
but i just i can't remember the last
time i played a computer game because
any spare moment i get i'm like well i
should be
working on something on youtube and so
it just i view very much as youtube is
my life at the moment
and everything else is kind of the not
the job
but the things that i attend and kind of
takes me away from
[Music]
youtube so where when you have a life a
normal life
you have to attend your job and that's
what takes you away from your life but
at the moment i feel like youtube is the
life
and everything that i'm doing is me
attending something
whilst youtube kind of is what i should
be doing
um so yeah it's a really taxing
thing mentally um
yeah just it can take it out of you but
i don't think
we're going to be doing this forever so
we just kind of have to knuckle down and
get through it and
you know i'm massively complaining it is
a great job when it's great
but you you will not have a personal
life or be able to book trips
and i wish that hollywood would just be
like let's just shut down for two weeks
yeah no news no tv shows just everyone
have a week off
i think it was around uh not last
christmas but the christmas before
because i
i personally have been living off of
you the channel since 2014
i want to say uh so 2014 i've been
living off of youtube
yeah so how do you last that long
mentally and just
that's a lot i've been i've been in
therapy for quite a while and
uh you know but even attending therapy
are you not just like
crap what if something happens i i've
gotten
a little better i say i have a big
emphasis on the little
like my fiance wouldn't say that but
people who knew me before would might
say that
you know what i mean because around the
time she because when she met me
it was during adpocalypse like i
remember when we were living together i
there was one point where i had to
borrow money from her just to make rent
and um so it was rough it was really
rough time
but i remember like it was
this christmas of 20 i want to say 2019
whenever there was like a spider-man far
from home trailer that was coming out
we didn't know when it was coming and
like this channel thrives so much off of
that
and we were supposed to go on a
christmas trip and i was with my
therapist
and my therapist was like
i know this spider-man trailer will be
big it would do great numbers you can
make a lot of money
but when you're old like if you were
gonna
she he laid it out to me pretty
straightforward he's like if you were
told you were gonna die
next week would you give a [ __ ] about
that spider-man trailer
yeah and i'm like no i really wouldn't
like i would watch it but i wouldn't be
like i gotta make a youtube video you
know
and yeah and uh not that i've like
adopted that principle
like every day you know like it may
supposed to be a lighter month
was like okay there's no big marvel show
let's try to take it easier and somehow
i'm still not sleeping
and yeah exactly the same
so i'm trying to that's why i'm like i'm
tr i'm doing my best to not
to be able to like clock out i like i'll
still check my phone
for stuff or like see my might be coming
out
like i used to like depending on the
trailer i
i'll really care about being first or
like close to first
but sometimes i'm like no it'd be better
if we're not so we can get some sleep so
that way we can have a better
performing video i feel like the quality
of our videos we can be better on camera
yeah
but i'm try i it's something that i
think
you're trying and i'm sure like it's
very
because i have like all these i put out
this long twitter thread yesterday about
like how
i have a script that's been with the
studio for a year and a half and i
haven't really been writing
since and i'm like it's i'm already not
sleeping doing youtube
and that's my fear about when i'm going
back into my other my my real passions
is like well now i'm just never gonna
sleep and i'm just gonna be a miserable
grumpy quick to provoke [ __ ] because
and then you'll write the machinist
because he knows he knows i get like
very uh
if i'm not if i go too long without
sleeping like that much i
i'm very easy to provoke like i get very
ticked off
about like the littlest thing going
wrong so
i don't that's funny it's like all i can
do kind of what you're saying all i can
do is be honest about where i'm at right
now
and i i don't really have a solution to
handling this and uh yeah as i think
like you know when we're talking
all of us you know because there's a
camera pointer at us we'll do our
disclaimers we'll talk about like how
you know like we know it's a great job
like yeah but when we're in private it's
like there is these like taxing
things that happen in uh where
it's weird like this seems like this
should be the most easy thing to have a
personal life but it's
because you're self-employed and you
don't have someone really
checking in like it's you you have a
nine to five you have a set schedule
it's it's weirdly harder when you're
your own boss or you're in that kind of
situation because it's like oh yeah you
can do whatever you want with the time
except it behooves you to really
organize that time and mostly dedicated
to what you're focused on
yeah but it's like even when building
this channel originally i was like
40 hours a week at a doctor's office and
then
30 hours a week i was doing youtube so
i'd do it bright and early and i would
do it late at night
and then eventually when you replace
that job you're like well all the hours
i had for my job got to go to youtube
now
yeah and now i'm like it's non-stop so
um yeah to really have this i'm kind of
looking for the for the solution and
it's really about just
willing to make a decision like last
christmas for wonder woman
i made the choice of we could do a
reaction to this
probably get a lot of patrons for
covering it probably make a lot of money
on youtube if we get it monetized
but my fiance really wants to watch this
movie
and so it's i could we could sit down in
a camera and do it together but
and i know i'm going to get comments of
people being like why didn't you do a
really there's a lot of that but i i
made the choice to go i prefer to watch
this with my fiance to have this moment
with her on christmas yeah
definitely that's really nice but it's
not i don't always do
[Laughter]
how many subscribers you get as well
you'll never feel secure
no it does doesn't matter i thought by
half a million subscribers i'd be like
oh any video i post will do
hundreds of thousands of views and now
sometimes like my resident evil village
breakdown i did yesterday it's on about
12 000 views and it's just like uh
just feels like a bit of a kick in the
teeth so now i feel like i have to work
more to kind of recover and get things
back on track but sometimes you'll find
that
just the way the algorithm works if
you're down
you'll get worse and worse and worse
because your videos are getting
recommended to less people because less
people are watching them
so it's constantly a downward spiral um
whereas there's some channels who
just post once a week like i really wish
i could be
like the canadian canadian yeah yeah and
just post once a week
and i i've got no idea if he
you know to me it seems like he's living
a great life and just doing
that work and i wish i could be like
that but he might be going through his
own things
and you really don't know exactly what's
going on with certain people
um and for me i just get such bad
anxiety if i don't work
and everyone's like oh you just post all
the time he's just
constantly on top of things and they
don't kind of see the psychological side
of that of like
well why does he do that and it's it's
because i get a lot of anxiety if i miss
out on a topic
or um if i'm not the first out
i i i have this belief of like oh crap
people aren't going to watch my stuff
they're going to watch someone else's
and that is kind of what drives me to be
you know always
um so people probably think like oh he's
the best he's the fastest man alive
but it's very much because in my head
it's like you have to work you have to
work you have to work which is really
difficult to switch off and when you
have that in your head the whole time
obviously it drives my channel to be you
know posting every single day but
it's yeah it can be quite torturous
almost
um when you don't have something to do
as well that's really really bad
so today i haven't posted and it's like
oh crap
what do i do oh yeah i get you like
leak this interview
i blow it up i have a philosophy of
i feel like every emotion when you boil
it down comes down to love or fear
and i actually love doing this but
weirdly
so much of the decision making stems
from a place of fear
and that's the contradictory part of
doing this
is yeah it's like yeah const
i mean it's weird to be like oh there's
a venom trailer on monday
cool that'll do well ah but i gotta get
up at five
in the morning it's gonna change sunday
and i gotta look awake and alert and
feel a natural enthusiasm so i gotta
like research venom
and there's a chance it might not be
monetized so it's it's tough
but yeah i don't know even though we
kind of know the schedule now where it's
always
for me it's either 2 p.m or 5 p.m still
jealous
most trailers get posted that time but
even then i'm still like
oh well i don't know and at one 1pm i'm
just like oh
what if this doesn't happen so my resume
video yesterday
i got i got that done and that was a big
that was very very taxing getting that
done but i had to get it done because i
thought if this venom trailer doesn't
drop
then i'm gonna have nothing to post
today
um so yeah it's it's just constantly
just
in the back of your head worrying about
things and you know worrying is an
overactive use of your imagination a lot
of the times but
you just constantly have the fear of
missing out
if you don't cover a topic and someone
else does and it blows up it's like
oh crap that i really wish i'd done that
i'm kicking myself for not doing it and
you don't want to feel that
you don't want to and you kind of feel
like you might let your subscribers down
as well
because that second loki trailer dropped
and and i had so many people i posted a
walking dead video instead and so many
people like this is a waste of time do
loki instead
but i'd literally been up in the morning
just working on this walking dead video
and i'd done the nevers as well so i did
two episode breakdowns back to back
and i just was like i just don't have
the energy to do it
um so yeah it's just really really
difficult
sometimes it's full of it it's funny
because like you really
people say this about us too but it's
it's it's difficult because we're on
camera a lot so we have to look like
you know yeah we have to look like yeah
we're always in a good way
and we gotta improvise good jokes
but you're uh i i never would have
as much as i've been along i've been
doing this i i still never would have
suspected
just from listening to your videos that
you do deal with the anxiety or the
the stresses like you just don't have
that cadence about you
your your narrations are so soothing
ironically
like when i listen to them in headphones
i'm like you should do audio books or
something
like this is so informative but also
it's charming and funny
yeah i guess that's kind of work does
feel like the release almost
like it's like i'm here and i'm doing it
and yeah that's kind of
where the anxiety just frees almost
sure you're in the zone so yeah like
yesterday with the venom trailer
i knew it was coming so i prepared my
intro prepared my outro
had that ready and then when the trailer
was here i'll say oh it's here
hit it hit the time i predicted i'm sat
down i'm ready to do this
let's just enjoy it yeah that was quite
good but it's the it's the in-between
that's really bad
yeah the anticipation anxiety and then
the assembly anxiety yeah the
anticipation of it
but like the night before a disney plus
show or even like the half hour before
that
it's like oh crap like because they've
been releasing disney plus shows at
weird times as well it was meant to be 8
a.m over here but sometimes they drop it
20 minutes before like 15 minutes before
so i'd constantly be sitting there just
refreshing
and yeah so and i i kind of
have trapped myself into being the first
person out i think
and whereas i would love to just be able
to think oh i'll just get to it in
another day i'll just
relax and take time off because i think
sometimes the videos do suffer
um for example yesterday i uploaded the
venom trailer
and then it got it got a claim on it and
it
i saw in the comments there was people
pointing out other easter eggs and i
just thought you know what i'm just
going to pull this video
i'm going to actually take my time with
it and it didn't do as well
but i feel like i'm more proud of that
video almost
you get a better video out of it yeah
exactly i was like
i was talking to chris about it i was
just saying yeah i'm more interested in
making
the best video i can and you know i
chucked away
20 000 views on it but you know the
the 60 000 people that have watched it
on top of that
they'll probably enjoy the video more so
exactly no it's that long-term effect
that you're talking about exactly yeah
and we we've been we've been doing our
best to adopt that principle
like for shanghai so difficult though
it's different especially when like the
reaction game where it's so easy to like
okay as long as we're
close to first we can like really ride
this wave of the algorithm recommending
us
but i do notice that like like even the
shang chi
trailer it didn't come out and we were
so pissed and it just came out while we
were in the middle of the middle of
something else
so then we had to rush it and i was like
i have i don't even like watching back
that video even though people really
liked the video and it went trending
i was like i wasn't a fan of the fact
that we rushed it and we didn't have
like
i just want to like for those rush ones
i want like at least a solid
you know how like the end of your venom
breakdown had like a really solid like
two minute review of the trailer
yeah i want like a solid four to five
minute review that's
it but like on the shong chi you're just
like hurry up get that [ __ ] opinion
guys all right now we gotta put the
thumbnail get it updated
and uh yeah i'm not a fan of when we we
get stuck in that mode
and so like for venom i'm like hey we
had a good four to five minute opinion
time
that was awesome sweet so then when it
got demonetized i was like
damn it of course the one where we were
like feeling sharp about this yeah
yeah yeah that'll always be how it
happens as well it'll always be the one
that you care about i mind getting
shadow band
yeah i know it was in shadow band but it
sucked but yeah this is the shang chi
one i remember
because the poster dropped so i'd
prepared quite a lot
and i can imagine damn yeah yeah
and the poster dropped so i thought i'm
gonna have to quickly change this so i
went back
rewrote loads of it and recorded it
and then as i came out to edit the the
audio
um i saw that the trailer was actually
live
so i had to scrap all that then hammer
out a new one
twist and change things and yeah it was
just i think you can kind of tell when
you watch the shanxi
trailer breakdown that there's a lot of
stuff in there that's just general
points about the characters
um which was just coming from me
preparing for this poster video that i
was going to do
but i didn't want to completely scrap
because then i'd wasted so much time
yeah so yeah it's it sucks when they do
that
but they don't care about us
they're just trying to troll you on his
back
but dude paul um i really appreciate the
time you had here appreciate the honest
conversation
this took a while to
because we kept trying to do it and
something else would come up
and we had to be like sorry this is an
important
this new trailer that's just dropped is
you know i understand i get it
we we get it yeah yeah we have to go
interview henry golding for snake eyes
right now okay cool do you have to be
good eddie snake
we have five minutes to learn all about
snake eyes so we don't know anything
about
we don't know as much as we needed not
as much as we ought
yeah so yeah we got five minutes to be
like oh snake guys
what's that about again yeah can you
demonstrate how you would break down a
character for a video in front of us
right now send us those notes
we'll let you know how it goes but dude
andy circus trailer breakdown
yeah that's the future just get the
director to do it for you oh i know he's
taking away your job
before we sign off i want to know where
did the beef with ign
start i actually quite like ign to be
honest
um i've spoken to some of them behind
the scenes and they were like oh we
really like your videos because i posted
one of their trailers
um with a watermark on it it was for
godzilla versus kong
and they were like we we this is kind of
exclusive to us can you just take that
down
so i said yeah but i just i'm always
throwing stupid shots out like that
yeah me and ryan arie have nothing but
beef all the time but we love each other
behind the scenes
um so yeah i'm just always making
because no one ever
like i said before we kind of all exist
in this bubble where no one really
acknowledges each other and so i think
it's fun to just do that from time to
time
so yeah absolutely but i don't have a
problem with ign they're fine
that should be the candy circus again
i'll kill you that should be the opening
of this video
just throwing shade at ign no context
[Laughter]
all right bob dude thank you so much i
know it's like thank you
it's late for you you started off our
day i really appreciate this
yeah so take care take care buddy you
guys subscribe to heavy spoilers if you
haven't done so
trust me well worth it take care buddy
kevin spoilers